Famous Hollywood actors are sometimes thought
of as superstars, but when it comes down it
they are just humans like everybody else.
And just like anybody else, they are subject
to fears and phobias that can interfere with
their daily lives.
We have gathered some of the strangest fears
for famous actors like Channing Tatum, Scarlett
Johansson and many more for our list of 10
Popular Actors With Weird Fears And Phobias.
Enjoy this video and be sure to hit that subscribe
button to get brand new Screen Rant content
every single day!
Channing Tatum – Porcelain Dolls
If you take a look at Channing Tatum, you
would probably think that he is one macho
man who is not afraid of anything.
Whether he is dancing in Magic Mike or wrestling
in Foxcatcher, Tatum seems to always be playing
a seriously jacked up man.
But just like Superman, Channing Tatum seems
to have his own kryptonite and for him it
is his crippling fear of porcelain dolls.
He says he is totally freaked out by them
and always has terrifying images of them turning
their heads around.
This fear sounds like the plot of a early
2000’s horror movie that we are sure Tatum
would not have wanted to star in.
Billy Bob Thornton – Old Furniture
Billy Bob Thornton is looking pretty old and
beat up these days and his latest acting choices
have certainly not been his best.
From what we’ve heard, Thornton can be sort
of weird to work with, but the weirdest part
about Billy Bob might be his peculiar fears.
The Bad Santa actor is, believe it or not,
afraid of antique furniture.
He claims that he is spooked by the old furniture
and feels like he is unable to breathe around
it.
His friends have even suggested to him that
he had a traumatic experience with some antiques
in a former life.
On top of that one, Billy Bob Thornton is
also afraid of bold colours.
Could you imagine what a wreck he would be
around a 300 year old bright red chair?
Orlando Bloom - Pigs
In the early 2000’s, Orlando Bloom was one
of the hottest and biggest male stars in Hollywood.
With leading roles in both the Pirates of
the Caribbean and the Lord of The Rings franchise
it seemed like he could take on anything.
Anything except for…pigs.
Yes, the swashbuckling, arrow slinging Orlando
Bloom has a serious phobia of pigs.
We are not sure where this fear comes from,
as pigs are actually some of the smartest
and most loving animals on the planet.
Bloom has not shared any real insight or background
on this fear and it is definitely one of the
weirder ones on our list.
Carmen Electra – Water
Although Pamela Anderson is probably the blonde
bombshell that people think of first when
it comes to talking about Baywatch, Carmen
Electra was right there with her on that beach
looking just as good.
It turns out that the filming of this often
ridiculed was actually very difficult for
Electra as she has a serious fear of water.
She has said that water, specifically open
water, gives her a real sense of danger and
that being near it can send her into a full-blown
panic attack.
We haven’t heard any specific behind the
scenes Baywatch stories, but from the sounds
of it, it may have been pretty difficult to
be on set with Carmen and her aqua-fear.
Helen Mirren – Answering The Phone
Helen Mirren’s weird fear is actually something
that is becoming more and more common these
days.
As texting becomes more popular, a lot of
people seem to afraid of talking on the phone.
As it turns out, the revered actress has had
a fear of phone calls for years and has even
publically shared that she never calls anyone
back.
She says that phone calls make her feel panicked
and uncomfortable.
Luckily, she has a team of assistants around
her to take her calls for her.
Matthey McConaughey - Tunnels
In the last few years Matthew McConaughey
has transformed himself from a rom-com hunk
to a seriously respected Hollywood actor with
great performances in Dallas Buyers Club,
Interstellar and True Detective.
The middle-aged stud seems to have gotten
past his goofy type cast, but it sounds like
he still has some strange fears he needs to
face.
McConaughey has let it slip that he has a
serious fear of both tunnels and revolving
doors.
We are guessing this could be considering
some type of claustrophobia, but we aren’t
sure.
All we know is that you probably won’t catch
McConaughey driving a Lincoln through a tunnel.
Uma Thurman - Claustrophobia
Uma Thurman is as gorgeous as she is badass
and her iconic roles in Tarantino’s classics
have made her a legend in Hollywood.
As it turns out, some of the great acting
that she brought to Kill Bill: Volume 2 may
have been more authentic than people thought.
Thurman told the press that her screams were
completely real in the scene where she is
being buried alive, as this is one of her
great fears as a person with claustrophobia.
Thurman is brave for facing this fear in the
name of her art and the final product was
awesome.
We just hope that she wasn’t left too traumatized
after shooting the scene.
Johnny Depp/Daniel Radcliffe - Clowns
Johnny Depp and Daniel Radcliffe are two huge
names in Hollywood who have both played iconic
roles in fantastical films.
Their shared fear of clowns, although strange,
is quite understandable, as we have to agree
that clowns can be creepy.
Depp has said that it is the make-up as creepy
smiles that get him, which is a bit weird
when you consider that that is what a lot
of his characters looks like in their movies
(Edward Scissorhands, Willy Wonka, The Mad
Hatter, etc).
Woody Allen – Everything
Woody Allen is one of most prolific writers,
directors and actors that Hollywood has ever
seen and the Academy has not been shy to nominate
his work year after year.
Woody’s personal life has always been rather
strange and borderline creepy so it only seems
fitting that the peculiar man would have the
longest list of strange fears we have ever
seen.
Over the years he has admitted that he is
seriously afraid of insects, sunshine, dogs,
deer, bright colors, children, heights, small
rooms, crowds, cancer and anywhere except
Manhattan.
That is a long list of things to avoid so
we can understand why Woody Allen spends so
much time cooped up alone.
They say the most brilliant minds are the
strangest ones, and that seems to be the case
here!
Scarlett Johansson – Birds
ScarJo is one of the most beautiful and sought
after actresses working in Hollywood today.
Her recent movie roles range from a superhero
spy to and flirtatious artificial intelligence
and everything in between.
Not only is Johansson a great actor, she also
brings a seriously stunning confidence to
each of her movie appearances but as it turns
out there is one thing that can shake that
confidence, and that is birds.
That right, if you are around Scarjo you better
make sure there are no flying and flapping
creatures around her or she may just freak
out.
She claims that this fear runs in her family
as her uncle also has a serious phobia of
birds!
So there’s our list of ten popular actors
who have some seriously weird fears and phobias.
Which one of these surprised you the most?
Are you afraid of any of the stuff on this
list?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!